[Music]
nothing's wouldn't go back to the way
that it was guys how do you keep what's
gonna happen on the show secret to
people is it family and friends just
berating you how do you think they know
to shut their mouths about it and I
don't we just have a lot of fun we have
a lot of fun doing it hasn't been that
bad security went up this year you know
we have to shred the strips at the end
of the day or whatever we talk to the
Game of Thrones people they told us what
to do because no one hasn't worst the
game of Thrones Season 2 what should
people be more afraid of two people or
the otherworldly creatures a little bit
a little bit of both I'd be more worried
about anything that comes from another
dimension we do have good new human
villain in this character Billy played
by taker Montgomery who was the Red
Power Ranger he's a phenomenal
Australian actor it's scary you know
season one you're worried that no one's
gonna watch it and now season two we
know people watch it which is great but
then people have expectations there's a
whole nother level of stress that's
added but I think at the end of a it
evens out how does it feel to just see
these kids like get recognized and have
this explosion out of this amazing I
mean because I mean they're like family
now they're genuinely a great group of
goods and so it's very exciting to see
their careers Hey
like a group text with them how do you
want to stay off the group's I met the
children it's crazy yeah it happened
before niche it's just tax I protect for
hours and it's it they're they're crazy
people sharp turns in the subject like
they don't they're very unfocused I
advise you not getting involved in that
pay off yeah maybe it sounds cool being
on a group text with the stranger things
kids know
[Music]